إذا كنت تريد الابتكار أو إذا كنت ترغب في
تطوير تقليد ما، عليك أن
تفهم هذا التقليد جيدًا، عليك أن
تعود إليه، عليك أن ترى
كيف تطور وكيف تطور،
اسمي لولو الحموت وأنا فنانة سعودية.
التركيز على إحياء الخط العربي
والكلمات العربية في الفن المعاصر،
كانت كتابة القرآن أحد
الأسباب الرئيسية لتطور
الخط العربي، لذا إذا أراد المرء أن يفهم
تطوره عليه أن
يفهم الثقافات المختلفة التي
اعتنقت الإسلام واتخذت من  القرآن الكريم هو
كتابهم المقدس، وقد
أطلق الخطاطون التقليديون تلك
الشرارة بداخلي وجعلوني أرغب في
القيام بشيء جديد بالحروف العربية
خاصة في الفن المعاصر [
موسيقى]
أنا لا أقتصر على القلم والورق، فأنا
أقوم بطباعة الفنون الجميلة والطباعة بالشاشة الحريرية.
الوسائط المختلطة كنت أرغب في
تجربة أنماط مختلفة،
أردت أن يشعر الناس بطاقة هذا
التكوين أكثر من فهم ماهية
الكلمة.
أعتقد أن الحرف العربي والكتابة العربية
هما الجانب الأكثر أهمية في
هويتنا، وأنا بصراحة أشعر بأنني محظوظ جدًا
لأنني
متخصص.  في هذا الموضوع لأنني
أشعر أنني أيضًا سفيرة
لثقافتي
[موسيقى]